[Music]
what is that ultimate accelerant oh [ __ ]
I got some kind of thing I got something
called ultimate accelerant
but I won't even have anymore oh my god
I need a backpack dude oh dear
teammate please don't I killed someone
why come to us come to us come unless
Jesus I'm not gonna be able to do any
what am I gonna do [ __ ] them up I
believe in you Christ he's like the
worst motivator you know I mean yeah
Pixies doors come on brother
you're here you're here see you made it
happen I'm in this building right here
here inside here wait I gotta close
condiments done the UFC all right there
we go
are we starting are you waiting on me
yes okay guys here we go again
now we got our guide this is worse far
team all together right now yeah this is
these are the best people who are
special parties that's a little logo
above me right there yeah little logo
above me you should click it right there
that's like a cartoon well you can't
click it I don't have any links give me
the girl you should be able to do that
thank you sound like we think hey this
girl's dog that she's being a little
[ __ ] he's got to be his [ __ ] he
[ __ ] I like this girl bang
she's a girl is that a girl I can't that
could be a guy right that could be a guy
know that right maybe that's our first
transsexual nah bro bro she's none
non-binary difference what you think
girl coke so you'd be the jumpmaster
why don't you just tell Stahl town I
don't see it so we're going there okay I
see it
so we jump now no we should wait no wait
wait I don't know if Pope knows who
aeronauts always do Renato oh what's his
last name he's so jujitsu God he's hella
funny
are we ready we could go down let's
write we're not we're not so uh a lot of
Red John I can't even say no good Leslie
apparently oh we should have we should
have got on that ship right there
we can't yeah I know I know you're
talking by BH designs credit let's go
let's see if we can make this make the
[ __ ] you can't make the ship
I'm trying we can't make it well so
we're going down here brother brother
has left me we're literally right next
to brother don't worry
yeah it looks better we got a squat end
up jumping right come on I need a gun
why is there a moan no gun that [ __ ] is
so infuriating or I have a girl oh
that's it
who's that oh that's me dude you don't I
tell you guys stop sneaking up on me
like hoho thankfully in this game you
can't last us all right over here
where do they gonna let four people play
- I don't like just three people play
[ __ ] that's not good oh brother I got
you brother I got you
Griffin be a distraction my face yeah I
I am gonna have green screen on my
podcast and change the background every
week y'all I'm asking you guys to send
out some backgrounds for me somebody
make a studio when I do my solo episodes
that's how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna get
a better camera just the old-school
Logitech right now this is just for
gaming but anyways let's go back to our
webcam read again here we are gonna try
and get a cab but you want to get a
better one there or you should just get
no I bought dude I bought the cam link
and [ __ ] doesn't work
actually I'm I kidding but no I just I
really should just buy another want to
spend another $400 you should just go
what I have a lot of tech c920
1080p all right I'm gonna do that
I'm waiting for my green screen to come
in so then I can cut out you don't have
to see my hoarder house yeah me not to
see your freaking family this is
ridiculous mmm is mom coming to the game
I don't somebody make me a studio and
then I'm gonna use it on my podcast I
already got some
I hope songs I think things are coming
in or dope if you move to LA that's a
dream okay what do I want to be yeah
okay people
he's totally Samoan Tongan dude he's
letting the guy from Ilana white guy I
don't know this the diversity on this
game is ridiculous guys because it's
[Laughter]
Apex legends yeah that middle one I'm
not sure we should just jump now go like
right here yeah let's just get out so we
don't have like a bunch of teams coming
at us we want to leave no I'm still I
can't pick a theme song guys because of
these songs that are coming in or Soto
every week I get somebody tops the
masked person so I can't pick eventually
I'm gonna have a pole discussion and
we'll do it you just give me this
longbow and there we go oh man somebody
took oh well
Pikachu that's what he does man I didn't
think [ __ ] yeah acknowledge it either he
just like okay today is not us oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude people keep running up on me
that's how you get blasted son
alright what's in here what's in here
all right I got my shotgun brother we
good nothing's in here I need some I
need a shield or something Bobby or
Griffin or Bobby or Steve sugar to
create Griffin's theme song I don't know
that would be dope
I want Steve Debbie that's it you know
what when you have Bobby and Steve on
you should have one movie like theme
song oh I know right that's the next one
we could be doing scary movies I think
I'm gonna have them on record that
episode next week I think are you guys
following me because I'm just following
the thing here's another building right
here oh here's some [ __ ] here's some of
these big crates oh yes there it is
y'all whoo a frag grenade
wait what gun is this this gun better I
don't know what's gonna is better oh I
want that
all right let's go that's right guys
spice this oh I like how the a shield
pops up when you shoot with this guy
he's got pretty good yeah no yes he
takes more damage too he's not as fast
but
let's explore this way
might be something good this way oh
there's a lot of chests over here look
at this
oh we're totally raid in this area
what's this [ __ ] see oh yeah EMR right
over here code if you want it right I
already got one now look I'm taking it
from this guy I don't want that can you
ask what happened to shield you and when
is coconut beyond repair if n I don't
know was any town there's people there's
people there's people oh no it's 15 what
I'm coming I'm okay brothers we need
assistance [ __ ] [ __ ] accidents
are they hey there split up Griffin stay
with Colt got one
[ __ ]
Griffin [ __ ] him up okay mom shoot your
gun hey maybe we should switch over to
back to call the duty no I like this
game I want to play yeah Pete she's
really bad at call duty this game I
think she is he thinks living zippy as
long as he has confidence in the game
then maybe that's all that's all that
needs to happen right that's all right
he feels like he's good he's good
okay I'm connecting to the lobby
[Music]
oh my god all right let's go back to all
things comedy studio
I'm coming is I got disconnected
oh then we have to stop should I stop no
you met I stopped it on those if all of
us already so good you're gonna watch
the fights this weekend a Coke or nah
nope yeah we gotta watch the fights yeah
for whatever it's lagging oh I didn't
put me Justin what yes I'm since I don't
even see you on like it just put me in
game that's weird brother there you go
yeah dude coke one more level up and we
can buy the skin do you have enough I
know one more one more
we gotta keep close keep playing huh
we're waiting for coke all right here we
go faster go faster if you got kills - I
do get killed I have more kills than you
do on this on your character right now
no overall you have more overall overall
you know overall yeah there's a [ __ ]
made character I get at least 3 kills
when I use that [ __ ]
okay cool story you [ __ ] easy bro
yeah this may be this is good ok I'm
maybe this is a white guy and he has a
really dark tan dude he's clearly Samoan
Italian dude yeah he's some awesome dude
look at this look at this [ __ ] thing
it has like [ __ ]
listen to his voice dude what you hear
the voice [ __ ] start without you
it's like we have to cancel battle
cancel it was an error again what the
[ __ ]
I'd already come ready I don't know
about that guy
how's the mic sound everybody I need to
know how to mic volumes good what's
happening give me some feedback Dan
they're saying come to powder
I don't think cokes a snack pattern
Hellmouth yes I play with these dudes
that's against the gate yeah he's mister
instigator man I love instigating
gentlemen get back to the chair I don't
think their facebook chat is people
aren't reach a ting from Facebook it's
kind of weird
this chat that I could see all the
checks he did wonder what he was playing
on his bunny earlier me a gap played a
game I'm sorry it was your left and we
got second again
oh you know what I could do oh man I
could actually FaceTime call you coke
and your face could be on the screen I
could just have a FaceTime call of you
you know what I'm saying sounds like
yeah you know me next time yeah that's
how we did it before that one time when
we were a chalupa Batman jr. thank you
for the five dollar donation coke Eagle
stat padder's yeah that's his message he
says you're pretty much out there that
patch that matter they ever a lot
multi-player I'll go get speaks you and
I'll [ __ ] ice and everything
I play aggressiveness [ __ ] Pete you play
super passive no I don't what's the
[ __ ] football all right let me get
hyped up
chant give me more to the right
macoco are you
right here okay all right there's hella
people here Griffin it's the area again
others others hella people here okay so
my bad my bad I'm over here looking at
the [ __ ] computer alright got a damn
that's never a gun oh god I don't want
this I want a rifle or something Guinea
tonic oh Jesus Christ
now the triple sink right here triple
sink when Adam I got it
oh no I didn't burn I do but no that's
not sure I got a good garden I think
girlfriend we need you we need your
shields and [ __ ] wait dude I'm trying to
get can I get guns okay so I could be
useful
dying
hater oh [ __ ] wait let's go oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
alright just mark Griffin I mean coke
them putting the heating bottle over
here
[Applause]
never [ __ ] them up [ __ ] them up just
call us Khurana I'll heal you ask
crowded hogatha shooting at me I got a
zigzag cross
yeah he's healing himself with a big
dude right next I was at Loyola by
telling you I get two people down man I
can't can't do it myself
dude I was trying I was there I was
shooting at that guy and then you guys
are so far behind I just can't I can't I
don't know what it's like
there's too much you have to do you know
you like you know yeah I'm trying to I'm
trying to get my grenade I don't know
which [ __ ] button the grenade is
it's you know I need your commentary
YouTube what is its name YouTube showing
you [ __ ] [ __ ] trying to tell me you
don't know me
here we go how does a tank die first all
right we're doing don't forget you have
an LBD okay I'm gonna be this girl oh
that's right I did forget about the LBD
see your friends character really looks
like him I don't know [ __ ]
I mean is such a piece of [ __ ]
introducing new a champion
[Music]
you know jumpmaster brother i'm the
jumpmaster yes finally some really could
make it do something good let's go here
here we launch Oh
oh [ __ ] are these people going to the
same place yep yep now they're going
what's free hook
one dropped early okay come on a student
oh my god I'm so nervous nervous time Oh
somebody right here already oh my god
[ __ ] nightmare man look I'm right
behind you I'm coming I broke as you
fall man anyways say hello to switch
right Facebook payload a periscope and
you too
guys look at all that wants to restream
pretty dope
[Music]
down here got here get out there I don't
have any more ammo
can't really do anything this guy put a
shield up yep nope he's on me and I have
no ammo
where the [ __ ] you know he just saw he
said he's on his own like he out here in
these streets all by himself he was he
was just telling somebody with Pete
shoot that's what you have to you go for
thirst [ __ ] kills kills that are
already see my god oh my I saved you
we're good are we good yeah yeah the day
I agreed Nate whoo there is a real
learning curve on this game god
what is that that's right guys you're
watching a pika TV
pika Pikachu Pikachu - pika TV TV oh no
there's too much well I got a hundred
thirty-two people watching on YouTube
that's nice
I got like 20
I'm trying to like get on the thing oh
here we go
oh hi brother
he's totally Polynesian babies do some
Compton man he's definitely from
Inglewood obscure minority legends yes
that's what someone sitting on my
challenge it DVD bright I'm jump faster
give they jump master brother can I get
some brothers in the shadow mister come
on
and everyone on Twitch can I get a bog
champ and the twitch chat please
actually let's hit the [ __ ] what's ship
oh the dude is flying yeah yeah I like
that I like going on the ship oh god I'm
scared brother
for retina
here we go
Oh chalupa thank you again for another
$5 donation the show loop looks and you
don't know
oh we're gonna hit this ship great but
then these [ __ ] beams come flying out
and okay there's a team to our left [ __ ]
I don't care guys might jump off to come
get us oh there's a guy took off there's
a guy that took off there's no frickin
guns here oh my god I hate having a guy
to make fish am i sure you put that out
there I need a gaming theme song cuz I'm
gay me
how did she get me it's like a rush I
finally have a freaking gun this guy
keeps [ __ ] sending messages do you
want to get blocked dude you got to get
block hey if someone cover world cover
my banner that'd be great
are you already dead I killed two people
that's cuz I stayed on the ship wait
wait hold on guys this guy yeah mark Moe
101 [ __ ] you you little spammy little
piece of [ __ ] don't don't talk [ __ ] to
me oh don't don't don't talk [ __ ] to him
though cuz you'll get banned
she just reporters block his ass look at
that guys spamming hi do it you go what
poor person how do you block them I just
want to block the poor person I think is
there a block there work
I just want to block this dude how do
you [ __ ] block people everyone you
see the gamertag harass them
I'll view from here now another view
profile I think you can be a view his
profile oh that's how you do it okay
yeah yeah I'm actually in the middle of
I'll do it after this one dansgame of
okay my banner Tom Bob do it I'm sorry
everyone watching pika TV I failed you
okay we're all right where's coke I'm
like off on my own here [ __ ] looting
all this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what is this I
don't know what that was is this a
better gun I think it is a better gun
that's a better gun now when you pick up
another gun wait does it keep the ammo
from the go yes it says brother I don't
know if I want this shotgun yes I do
wait is this a shotgun is this better
than the one I have Lex what are you
using [ __ ] I don't know why dear bro oh
yeah that was good that one's good it's
Auto shotgun okay
without a license
or just a bunch of [ __ ] oh no oh [ __ ]
what is this ultimate accelerant what
does that do I need a backpack it makes
sure uh if you're using a gun that has a
charge up time we got an issue sensor
uh-huh it'll help you got your faster
wait we need to go this way well I'm
[ __ ] in the wall I don't like the map
do but not I just sort of figured it out
like where the arrow is pointing that's
where you go almost dead
almost a marker where to go well I'm
coming for you guys right now for you
guys I got my super looks [ __ ] the ring
is closing oh my god right brother you
gotta go I'm coming you're fine you're
fine
we're literally right buddy I see you -
oh it's gonna touch you it's been
bleeding
that means they're headed that means are
closed and they're headed towards you
know wherever
I'll be right back Stream I'm gonna get
some snacks where are you gonna get some
snacks we're in the middle of a games on
dummy I think someone else we got a
freaking Mook oh you're dead oh no your
daddy's been dead oh [ __ ] I don't even
know that you're stupid kills
so just this one you can't get up there
like that
no [ __ ]
yeah I just did it [ __ ] you peace wait
how do we get oh man is there some kind
of way through this [ __ ] oh yeah okay
here we go
there's like an opening over here Kok
where I'm at we'll meet when it's time
to move forward yeah we can go now I
don't like there's much going on there
oh yeah there's a whole thing right here
a chest nobody's open so we're like way
ahead
oh [ __ ] look at this stuff do you need a
helmet sorry gotta help hey there's a
desk Oh
all right I'm back stream I got I got
some pretzel pretzel M&Ms literally
nobody sings my Sriman oh look where's
my team ever there's another one there's
some kind of like sniper stop and a
sniper or six times sniper scope I don't
have a sniper [ __ ] my [ __ ] backpack
over a few hundred just full with
nonsense
that circle so you can go through the
guards there's an absolute lot but I got
Russell mmm
no no I have a kit kat bar right here
what would you do that's alright jingle
but and I got a Reese's Pieces to climb
back yeah it's what if I [ __ ] want it
to be oh [ __ ] there's labels oh there's
a people guy here where give that
brother kill that brother I could buy a
new heaven put up your ship for lb lb lb
lb so annoying don't get a kill
I remember lb I killed him and you can't
um you said you got three kills we got
one and yeah yeah one [ __ ] monster
[ __ ] booze isn't over here God like
he got one guy down and he tried to
thirst the hell out of him that's what
gets a guy down and he just [ __ ]
tries to kill oh my god about anything
else going on around
that's not guys go back to all things
comedy you have to click a so you can
get a girl that can teleport what you
want to treat a different character
immersion you trying to be the girl
different doesn't know how to use that
chick yeah what are you talking about
doesn't make any sense what you're
saying
we're gonna get back to the chat sorry
Chad I've been looking at the chat oh
there's something going on with the
audio in the video
[Music]
you got one do you using this sexy
bedroom voice that must be me what's up
how you doin
that's sexy
[Music]
this is my turn to pick
oh I didn't even know you are warning
[ __ ] around singing I didn't get the
pic I have one kill
I'm not oh my god you know what I love
people that think they love to tell me
how to do my [ __ ] you should do this I
think you know do a good picture yeah
what you want to go [ __ ] face you
know what my [ __ ] screen we're going
to the ship get onto the ship again
telling me how to do my [ __ ] where is it
I'm looking for it you see it you see it
yeah the Lee brothers there come on can
we go do it once a month it's only been
like three okay well get on the ship you
lose ship again get off
come get the [ __ ] out of here come on
here we go here we go give me a [ __ ]
gun that guy shot me I need some healing
you're fine I got a gun oh here we go
yes give me this
what is that oh why you shooting me come
on you don't just come running up on me
like that all right
I'm running the coke I don't want to die
that's gonna help because you
there's a lot of shooting going on over
here what is that I don't know the [ __ ]
that is oh [ __ ] now you did I'm dead god
damn it
so fury eight put up that shield on this
box Pikachu
are you doing just throw it no kid
leader I don't know do you think Steve's
playing this game is free lay down a
plan I gotta hit him up
what does he even play these days he's
playing who the [ __ ] knows dude yeah
what game is few pointers I'm getting
jacked from the right yeah I'm gonna
text you guys I'm gonna text Bobby and
Steve well they can't they're never a
lot of play video games with us neither
one of them like teach you what you just
did right there like that's the [ __ ]
we're never gonna win a game if you
don't push people you sit so far back I
was not okay in my defense you know
Griffin got down and then you okay
Griffin remember I'm the medic guys yeah
yeah yeah I hear your pick man just
leave me alone
right now okay he's trying to games out
I'm testing it out this is the infancy
of my podcast okay you know just try and
[ __ ] out so Melissa can you give me a
break you know
[ __ ] man ok yeah this guy why they all
look like they're like he's like doing
like a a [ __ ] squat yeah yeah Griffin
remind you of Lonzo balls pins can you I
love our mawla Griffin's love our ball
mr. humble balls water balls like I'm a
boss I don't got no boss cuz I'm a boss
I'm changing characters there you know
non-binary character
do you remember to throw your smoke
grenades are hella good ok hi how do you
get the smoke grenade lb lb the left
bumper button oh he'll be oh god if I
would see these [ __ ] you're the
jumpmaster [ __ ] chat is so funny bro
call time of course coke chooses a full
time VPS chasing those kills first dance
this Craig I'm relinquishing her it's
for we going
I really clear that there ever any other
jet master no I'm not what happened I
relinquished just follow me
look a graphic follicle where is he I
can't see him
these abilities the blue
he's already leaving us this is exactly
what happens
pama we're following you brother
oh [ __ ] I got a jumpmaster thing I'm not
gonna go here cuz you guys come here I'm
not taking anything can I get the auto
shotgun first blood give me a gun I
don't want oh my god when you get rid of
that don't have some good [ __ ] Nixon
good [ __ ] next to something that's not
good okay here we go what's this
okay I'm coming to you guys where I
paint it brother get up there you can
just come just come right here hold a
and then you climb up oh oh [ __ ] where
just hold this thing like this you want
this shotgun Pikachu come get it yeah
wait wait do I have
sniper stock over here no gotta get I
got to [ __ ] hand cannons that's
actually like this thank you
oh my god a wing load watch them snow
trying to send me I don't want to play
with you I'm playing right now you
should just make yourself alright
I opened up this who extended mag follow
me out would what nothing I want this
one get rid of this one
that's right give us your energy check
its devotion
whatever you guys are okay oh man I kind
of like that no one's over it oh no this
there's two crates over here another
crowd I didn't take other stuff in that
other crate
we're not that go over there give it a
shield standed nag energy weapon okay
all right
don't come over here then why does not
however good there's a there's a hell
knock their dope oh [ __ ] look at the
graphics on this man oh there no in the
water we got the full auto mod for the
Prowler
yeah bean business boys did you guys go
in this building right here this gun is
a hundred percent of ripoff of halo yes
it literally looks exactly like it stay
with us Griffin stay was we're gonna go
on the ship Griffin where are you over
here I put a ping put a ping I'm coming
you guys left some [ __ ] over here yeah
we don't need that [ __ ] you think
anyone's on this great coke wow I'm cold
all right let me think the right one I
got my shotgun people like I want to see
my gamertag pop up on the screen guys
just stop [ __ ]
I feel like it's been looted already I'm
gonna climb a ladder
yes polluted so you got a grenade
hey blue all marmoreal up here oh yeah
there's nothing here Coco Co are you
[ __ ] here take this or give me the
blue one you're the best player well
that should tell you maybe you need more
armor all we got turn around
kind of Wambach line that's right stream
bumbaclot
all right we're in the circle while
there's some unopened crates over here
yeah
oh there's a bunch of them oh great
Kurt Kurt Kurt Kurt only reading no I'm
reading all the chats guys I could see
you in the twitch I'm reading the
Twitter all the chats coming to one chat
that's pretty guilty bundles hi twitch
chat I could see you if you're in
channel [ __ ] let's get a pop champion
or twitch chat feels all like oh [ __ ] I
can't even [ __ ] kidding me
these backpacks don't hold enough [ __ ]
man where are we going where is he I'm
gonna worry it [ __ ] I see him I see him
steady right Matt good [ __ ] I needed
that
hey there's gunfight over here okay bro
oh I see him you see where they're
fighting
no no cuz we're not even there but we're
on our way brother first first you know
I mean of course Jesus of course know
how are you guys so far back because we
don't want this guy
there we go we got a drop on him over
here
[ __ ] that team you guys all right hey
what's up Vince Sharma thank you for
saying show blah blah I can't drop oh my
god
yeah cooks this I talked about before no
I have one less termite YouTube is
better than Twitter but I'm also on
periscope
y'all need to know about that game yeah
I don't know about that periscope game
they put up a shield brothers brothers
focus
do a grenade hospitai sure god I don't
see him they started oh there we shot
right all right Tata me that we crave
with the Ravens URI where's it coming
but up your shield I'll be up for name
they got me Griffin put up your [ __ ] of
a throw so what is happen why am i
burning up it did the ultimate and they
just put up their shields they're gonna
go kill Griffin right now you're a shot
from a just [ __ ] direction
yeah and I'm about to
well in a bomb zone they think they did
their ultimate did you have your
ultimate grandpa yeah but you could have
done what they did to us okay we'll see
I hate you so much
yeah I mean like seriously we're so
close
where are we where are we big at you
where are we so close it's crazy I'm
trying to watch our joint which I'm sure
they're just getting furious just giving
a serious Jeff sloppy this is so good it
was terrible
oh my god dude oh we doing it one more
game one more game
this is it guys one more gaming that
we're out I want to thank you for coming
to riffin Griffin
[Music]
live from all things comedy Studio
Griffith gaming
and thank you for your patience money
Compton guy again Todd in this show no
that's shown up from last dragon hey
what's up peanut welcome
this is your champion this is your
champion
I'm the jet master we're going for the
ship for this trip we're going for the
[ __ ] ship we're gonna put a ship he's
Mexican job I can believe that
he's not a Mexican Mexicans don't say
that you don't know what he's Somali
that's Frank Jesus I'm jumping off jump
off jump pop jump pop jump pop jump pop
different jump off [ __ ] gun
everybody's like digging shoes always
running
yeah you gotta move fast on this quick
hitting me I'll recover you will recover
you mean Coco getting guns and we'll
recover you you can't recover me yeah we
can't mean we can over you're bad we can
recover your banner and revive you
brother
ping my back I just ping my banner well
I'm down again guys coke let's go enough
of them I mean I don't have [ __ ] i'm a
peacekeeper
that's nice man chat is just [ __ ] big
ruthless man I hate this chat I love you
chat turns out he was shooting at the
team and something on a rock that is
accurate as [ __ ] [ __ ] you accurate I
know I should have just jumped off but I
got cocky as I had a gun and I was
shooting right at the guy you guys stop
there's a guy right oh it's a mirage
it's fog we got 12 seconds to get to 10
seconds to get to Griffin ah well if you
had to been bullshitting me you just
came right to me we wouldn't have this
problem
how are you did now you're not gonna get
me Wow
and maybe get some good loot let's go
check this is my teammate right now you
could have but you could have got me up
the thing is right there - I know but
like we had again again we should just
kill herself so we can do one more game
on Griffin
I mean we gotta find somebody okay
alright let's let's just go guns blazing
over here I see you
there's down roof yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
them up oh you're gonna [ __ ] them up
this guy guys watch Pikachu's gameplay
get that guy nice long gone don't hang
that thing no I did not there we go what
are you making a phone call what is that
hey close the door oh you better die the
guy's right there Oh
open the door real quick did you jump
back
why you know why we can't get any
support for Pikachu shoot you're good
it's a pump shotgun they let their live
it's not an auto shocking it's a pump
from a terrible guys oh my god
yeah donate worse facts a member of
thank you for watching if you want to if
you want to donate please go to worst
fire team this guy happy donates kids do
ok right I'm coming I'm still in here
brother and not give you my life save my
mother of I know is there anybody [ __ ]
him up no he just kind of like a limp
look like a sex robot
you see that what good you have oh man
there you go shot get the kill get that
kill no matter what the kill matters who
are the new team cue eater you could
possibly get Pikachu
oh this is so nerve-racking right now I
gotta what pony the mod moderate no way
do one more you died hella quick we're
not gonna go to this is my outro we're
not gonna go on the ship well we'll do
one will do series one more guys we're
doing one more one more for the brothers
booty is hurt sitting on this chair
booty pop if you're a gaming chair
company a girlfriend would like a gaming
chair for ya what is chair company's
down out here boys you need a gaming
chairs you need some gaming headsets
Griffin we're waiting on you oh sorry
here we go y'all with ethnic legends
[Music]
we got a job to do such [ __ ] your [ __ ]
this is gonna suck goodbye
[Music]
yeah if you want to donate because
people are saying in your chat just go
to the worst party member YouTube that's
livestream it and you can donate through
their collab super chat enabling super
chance how you donate yeah but you
should know that you shouldn't do I got
it why you get taxed and [ __ ]
you guys need extra time you should just
give all the money to us even though we
split it equally this [ __ ] the
Griffin needs a bean bag yeah I need
like a blue booty pillow a booty pillow
booty pillow company out there booty
pillow I'm still on this back to the
game stream here we are y'all cocaine
the jumpmaster
I know all right Shane give us your
energy this is the game wrong he's gonna
go really far in this match I believe it
let's do it
where's the door on this [ __ ] yeah
there we go big old [ __ ] fence
Jesus okay girl there's some [ __ ] in
here super right off the [ __ ] bat
let's go into spit give me that give me
that here oh [ __ ] what is this I don't
know what this is but I'll take it
we got extended mag give me that frag
top there's footprints over here there's
someone over here I was over here those
me know I don't know man
oh man I need to just swap out I don't
know what this is that was not oh no
it's not over here it's not over here
yeah yeah okay where are you guys hey
you are
okay this cake looks beautiful though I
gotta say yeah oh wait it there's
somebody crawl up crawl up
did that healing me I want to [ __ ] it
away let's go crawl back in back get
back in here back in here back in here
after just one over here here boys
oh my god how do i okay wait I gotta use
oh my god I'm so confused right you guys
shoot the whole squad I gotta recharge
my shield again I'm gonna have the
healing thing in ten seconds okay okay
I'm just picking up these [ __ ]
grenades all right here we go
[ __ ] that was a blast that was intense
but I came in question
dad they gotta put the circle like all
the way on the opposite [ __ ] sign it
every time all right let's go to the
circle to go way to butt-fuck ii oh [ __ ]
we gotta go as hella far away from us I
had I had no idea it's gonna be this far
brothers we gotta go
one well you gotta go guys
where you guys at
you know what we have to go up here
there we go here we go if you hold the Y
Griffin you can holster your weapon you
can order faster oh that's nice
you learn something new every day holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] Marathon what the [ __ ] was
some shooting up here don't worry about
it I'm confident in us here that
everything is confident yeah he's
confident oh look at this though I'm
grabbing this yes I'll take I came to
take that we got to go we can't be over
here yeah we can't be dilly-dallying
over here ring is closing well this is
this is nonsense right now nonsense
look how far we are we just keep ready
just keep running
I believe we're gonna be fine happiness
we're gonna run into like another group
well we're gonna [ __ ] them up but grew
Souls check it was the energy oh my god
your package
well I think I made a wrong turn no
we're good we're good here we go
damn he could choose character got a
booty owner huh look at that wagon oh my
god
yeah chased Kimmy a girl come here don't
you because that booty is just wiggling
oh you can do side bends or sit-ups
please don't lose that but actually
that's actually a fanny pack huh
remaining remaining we don't have to be
so aggressive now that's why we come
with this area stay frosty just people
shooting to the right to the south
there's gunfire to the south currently
for Coke wait for Coke wait for copay
for Coke I'm not here I'm not doing any
place I'm going the [ __ ] I'm going to
talk follow me come back to me hmm
come to coke dude we need to get into
the circle oh yeah right I'm going there
there's teams over here where I'm almost
in the circle
on the outskirts here oh there's teams
right here
they killed me what's the point of a
shielded [ __ ] get this
equipment Achilles I know
Pikachu his so damn far
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright let's go to cope
now let's coconut attempt to get us up
y'all
okay cokes gonna get your banner and I'm
gonna make it into the zone oh yeah they
fight they're shooting my body so you
can get me dude
oh [ __ ] alack told you Griffin sugar
King oh that's beautiful
what the [ __ ] gun is that that's that's
well we tried to get a good shot with
that gun it's like by it's the sound
guys it's the forget Pikachu with smoke
pika can I do my outro first before you
[ __ ] do your [ __ ] outro god no I
got do it all over again
ah guess what I just so much all right
thanks guys for watching and we'll have
some more I got a big keep watching
rhythm to Griffin and I got Ponder's
from workaholics coming up next sucking
look out for him on Monday if you like
you some on ders only one person left
Adams when he gets back into town i'ma
get Adam and also Wayman is coming on
the show guys wait don't wait we got
four Wayman yeah so that you you'd be
surprised how much that [ __ ]
talks all right guys that's funny
Griffin Oh
Iko let's play another one cuz I know
y'all unlocked it let's do right